scarlett and i were both so small and we
didn't fit the car
and we needed to be punched up so much
so that we were on the same level um and
uh i just found that really funny that
in amongst this really badass
getaway scene we're also on these
cushions to make us seem bigger
it was just very new very classic movie
making
[Music]
hi i'm scarlett johansson and i'm
florence pugh and we're going to be
breaking down a scene
from our new film black widow
[Music]
okay anytime now please shut up
we got that scene in a practical
location and then we also
did a lot of pickups in the studio and
in the studio we ended up shooting in
this
rig which was kind of like a car with
you know
no windshield or like half a door or
like
you know no doors or it's like half a
car you know you're shooting it in all
these different ways
uh depending on where the camera has to
be and i remember that particular rig
was so
strange because it moved it had these
very like specific
movements that were programmed in uh i
had never
worked on like a robotic uh car rig like
that before
um and i don't know if you remember that
florence but there were very specific
ways that we were supposed to look when
the car
was like rotating around and it was uh
it was kind of technically challenging
um
yeah it was because we didn't know what
it was that we were looking towards what
was happening so for example in that
um exact clip that you just showed with
all the the gunshots and the glass
coming in
every single time we turn around we
didn't really know what it was that we
were looking towards or what was coming
together so it was like
and now react to the back window and
you're just kind of just having to guess
what's there which is always fun
[Music]
i i was just going to say that i think
whenever you're doing those
action set pieces where there's a lot of
moving parts literally
and then also like over many days and
you're kind of
doing these it's very piece meal and
there's all these different kinds of
rigs and stuff like that
the challenge is always like keeping up
your energy
and making sure that like the stakes
feel high
and like you're in the moment because
that stuff you know you
you know just it's just hard to
continuously have that kind of high
acting
like you know no holds barred kind of
thing
and uh you know feeling because you want
the audience to feel like there's
consistency even though you shot it over
weeks of time and all these different
rigs and sometimes florence would shoot
without me or
she wouldn't even be able to be there
and i was acting against nothing there
you know whatever
so it just you just have to remind
yourself
like kind of moment every you know
throughout the day
of what happened right just before this
how we got in this situation
like where are we at in the story and i
mean that's always that's always kind of
the challenge i think with these
larger like that pieces also um when we
were doing lots of the budapest stuff it
was it was
peak summer there and it was so hot so
we were doing all of these running
sequences on rooftops
and the rooftop would be so hot it could
melt
and so kind of adding that to the uh
equation of
being tired and having to sprint
when you're just wet underneath your
clothes i think that was the for me that
was the trickiest thing was like
constantly being ready to move when your
body is like i need to shut down
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
well your plan sucks
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our second vehicle uh change and
we are on the escape
and we every single time we've changed
vehicle we're narrowly escaping
the baddies and um you're kind of just
being able to see for the first time
their sisterly kind of arguing dynamic
and it's all nitpicking it's all
uh nothing's good enough for elena
your natasha's doing everything wrong
and she's just being that classically
annoying younger sister that's just
finding fault in absolutely everything
so much so that i have to take it into
my own hands and
knock a door off and then says you're
welcome which is the most annoying thing
ever
um but yeah no we had a lot of fun
shooting that and
as i said i actually couldn't hear at
the same time in the video
but scarlett and i were both so small
and we didn't fit the car
and we needed to be punched up so much
so that we were on the same level um and
uh i just found that really funny that
in amongst this really badass
getaway scene we're also on these
cushions to make us seem bigger
it was just very very classic movie
making
[Music]
you're welcome really this movie is a
kate shortland film
it feels like a kate shortened film and
it was really important
for her fingerprints to be all over this
and i think that's when marvel is most
successful
is when you know the filmmakers that
they are working with have a very
specific point of view
and they have the confidence to you know
inject
their own you know uh artistic vision
into like
the whole you know marvel cinematic
universe um and kate is just incredibly
confident you know she has no tolerance
for anything that
feels like fake or corny
or anything like that she's just very um
she's very real and she strives for
depth and realness
and um you know this movie is very very
grounded because of her
because of that i also think one thing
that i really appreciated and fell in
love with about her
and the process of making all of our
action fight sequence getaway sequences
was just how emotional everything was
and she really wanted to make everything
very human
and all of the decisions that you make
in that split second
it wasn't just about the action it was
about why have you made that decision
and how does that make you feel which
sometimes get lost when you when you do
have
um the big you know explosions and the
big getaways and
even just our first fight scene that
scarlet and i did there was so much
raw emotion and and kind of just two
very
talented and skilled women emotionally
fighting each other and
um i've never seen anything like that
before and i've never done anything like
that before so that was really lovely
and that came directly from kate
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
[Music]
between what the world wants you
[Music]
i made my choice
i'm done running check out black widow
available to watch now
[Music]